hi I'm Ryan no no that was cool that was
no I was impressed I was impressed and
we're gonna be watching yet again
another trailer for a movie that I
remember the title - it's called killers
that's what's called killers it's not
about the band no someone requested this
and I feel like such a douche and I
remember the guys name right now sounds
promising
it's about as well you know I'm sure
it's about death in some ways yeah I
mean it should be look at my sweater
it's got a killer on it yeah she said
she's gonna eat my weight doesn't make
any sense he tried to be sexual with it
it didn't work well it seemed like it
could be a little sexual I mean you make
anything
you mean me or anyone can you me thanks
it's my thing
sex jokes all right time to kill time to
kill you ready kill guys we're gonna
kill we're gonna kill we're gonna kill
y'all
yeah I'm sure this is exactly the kind
of film this is - just a bunch of
gangsters
Kazu ooh this onion was selected
there we go saya don't worry I still
know what we're saying he's given her a
flower two men with nothing in code
what's happening was he humping I guess
he's the killer
it's scarier because they're an Asian
down by a deadly secret
what was that on his screen I don't know
we're about to find out oh yeah because
we can it makes you feel this [ __ ] no
way
and so this is an action bump
just a second one halibut irritability
so I guess the message is that it's
about so tell me what's next well we're
gonna watch it - yeah yeah it's like
inside us lies a killers yeah um what is
that I don't know okay
new into trailer reactions for you guys
this is the banshee it just looked
really freaky from the Thunder this
little guy especially enhanced mm he was
not what I like about you experiments
did take place this little chemistry
experiment goes sideways I want you to
finish my book and dedicate it to me we
took a military grade chemical that no
one seems to have any documentation of
then his friend is also missing
you don't like this it can see me
was pretty scary actually
I can't watch them it I start to believe
this [ __ ] you know as much as I let go
it's a movie it's fake I start to
imagine this yeah it's like every noise
like like every creak you hear you just
like stare in a direction until you know
it's clear I used to sleep with a knife
when I was alone I used to be really
scared no.11 kid actually like after
watching a horror film he was like four
or five like after watching horror film
he was in his house alone his parents
like left for a little bit to go outside
when they came in they scared him so
much that he actually like had a heart
attack and died he was like so young
yeah so like it can your mind can do
crazy things and when you get really
into a moment like the littlest things
can trip out of your body it's crazy
dude what a sad story you know I don't
think he was that young but it was
around it was an age that of course he
wouldn't like have a heart attack
normally yeah yeah yeah maybe he just
had like really high triglycerides or
think about it when you're that young
like your mind what nuts with
imagination yeah probably this is real
do you think those parents had kids
again
we should right what happened I scared
my kids to death